eight nine ten
ten rings huh
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10.
what do you think well i suppose that's
one way to get me to care about this
movie
hello internet welcome to film theory
where we've always been with you
watching guiding making you cringe and
seeing you accomplish wonders like the
time that you managed to pick up the
phone without screening the number first
that was truly miraculous so get this
eternals is the last mcu feature film to
not be a part of an existing series or a
property that's been adapted before that
is kinda crazy when you think about it
the company's announced this massive
plan for movies going forward into 2023
and beyond and yet none of them are
actually original and honestly based on
the negative early reception to eternals
yeah they probably won't want to be
taking that chance again anytime soon
anyway it's kind of like the youtube top
10 creator tool that measures each of
your last 10 uploads ooh endgame number
one upload not surprising but good to
see shangshi solid performing on average
eternals 10th place ooh buy a lot wow
not not great gotta follow that one up
with the banger so the channel doesn't
die fire up a spider-man anyway
regardless of quality or public response
it legitimately makes eternals pretty
darn special add to that the fact that
it was written and directed by double
oscar-winning director chloe zhao a
self-described marvel comics fan who was
originally approached by marvel to
direct black widow but after passing on
that project sold them her own pitch to
make this movie again pretty cool you'll
notice however that one key thing i'm
avoiding talking about and that's the
plot because uh well i don't get it and
yeah that about sums up a lot of the
internet's initial reactions to this
movie days after its release this is a
weird movie that takes a lot of risks
after all this is a movie that's full of
philosophy morality and the nature of
human existence and usually if someone
in a marvel movie asks why are we here
the answer is obviously to punch that
bad guy and then they do and then
spider-man makes a movie reference and
one of the older guys with goatees does
the sarcasm reaction and then one of the
funny sincere characters does the
deadpan reaction and one of the serious
mother figures goes ugh boys and
everybody laughs but not in this movie
in eternals it suddenly yeah but but no
seriously i'm feeling existentially
unmoored about the nature of my place in
the universe and i think we should take
a long break in act 2 to talk this thing
out if nothing else this movie will go
down as marvel's first uncomfortable
sexy time scene yeah parents there's a
spoiler alert for you surprise they're
nudie and doing stuff in a marvel movie
i'm sitting there watching this on
opening night and the parents in the
audience are all collectively stiffening
at the same time as they frantically
tried to decide how to deal with their
kids sitting next to them it was a
palpable uncomfort in the audience gonna
have a fun time explaining that one to
the kiddos on the way home in short
eternals for winding up as a quote
unquote lesser marvel movie actually
gives us a lot that we need to talk
about because of what it's trying to
accomplish outside of getting me to buy
alexis that is go for gingo where are
you i'm almost there
parking the avengers wouldn't be late
exhilaration is eternal in the first
ever v8 lexus is 500. this one film
completely rewrites the entire history
of the marvel cinematic universe while
also upending the future of where things
are headed and not just in the usual way
marvel movies tend to with some brand
new person showing up in the middle of
the credits and saying his catchphrase
where half the theater goes oh he said
the thing so let's actually talk about
some of the more exciting stuff starting
with what i think is the most
interesting and important reveal of all
eternals proves that thanos was right
again alright so without recapping the
nearly three hour run time of eternals
i'm just gonna focus on the stuff that
you need to know the earth is pregnant
isn't it obvious morty
in the marvel universe what humans
consider gods are actually massive
cosmic space creatures called celestials
who we've actually seen before in the
mcu via the guardians movies peter
quill's dad ego and guardians the galaxy
2. what are you exactly i'm what's
called a celestial sweetheart this big
guy during the collector's speech in
guardians 1
and the giant skull where the
collector's base is nowhere yep that's
actually a celestial head anyway the
celestial's main thing is mucking around
with evolution with the help of their
lab assistants the superhuman robot
eternals and ugly monster deviants and
this is to help them survive you see it
turns out that the celestials reproduce
by laying their eggs inside the core of
planets because the life cycles of
living beings evolving for generations
provide them the billions of years worth
of energy that they need for those eggs
to gestate and earth has one of those
eggs the celestial tiamet is inside of
earth waiting to be born which would be
cool except for one teeny tiny detail
when the newborn celestial hatches it
destroys the planet and kills every
living thing on it so yeah earth is
suddenly on a doomsday clock or would be
if it hadn't been for everyone's
favorite giant purple raisin man thanos
in what might be the darkest implied
twist in marvel universe yet it turns
out that before earth's mightiest hero
saved the universe from thanos thanos
saved earth from the celestials
apparently the emergence of tiamet was
unscheduled to happen a few years ago
but got delayed because something cut
the population of the universe and thus
the egg's power supply in half hmm
in half you say perfectly balanced this
whole thing should be and when the
avengers assemble to snap everyone back
into existence suddenly tiamet was back
on the clock to hatch which wouldn't you
know is the main threat of this movie
and that's not the only way that thanos
helped out either the eventual pulling
together of humanity to undo the snap
turns out to be the tipping point that
gets a member of the eternals to turn
against their master and stop the
emergence so does that make thanos
earth's mightiest hero kinda yeah sure
the avengers saved half of humanity but
thanos literally saved the entire planet
adding insult to injury the fact that
the avengers undoing his work puts
tiamet once again on the fast track to
hatching that only strengthens thanos
case but here's where things get really
interesting was this intentional or not
did thanos know what he was really doing
when he snapped everyone away or was
this just some lucky coincidence i think
that there's a case to be made that he
knew what he was doing but maybe he
couldn't articulate it let me explain it
all starts off with three key lines from
infinity war first listen to him
describe the fall of titan titan was
like most planets
too many mouths not enough to go around
and when we faced extinction i offered a
solution they called me a madman
and what i predicted came to balance
notice that he says extinction here and
it's kept very vague we assume the
extinction is related to the planet's
lack of resources since that's what he's
talking about but what if the extinction
was coming from another source a
celestial source feeding on those too
many mouths because there's another line
earlier about the nature of the planet
titan and it feels off what the hell
happened to this planet
it's eight degrees off its axis
gravitational pull is all over the place
titan isn't just a dead planet where
people died due to a lack of resources
it's a planet that has been
fundamentally altered as peter quill
points out the gravitation on the planet
is weird it is somehow off its axis that
sort of cosmic change doesn't happen
just because a planet runs out of food
and water that comes from a celestial
popping out of this thing like a giant
kinder egg something more happened on
titan that we didn't think to question
way back then something that i suspect
even thanos himself might not have been
super sure about if life is left
unchecked life will cease to exist
it needs correct you don't know that
i'm the only one who knows that remember
that throughout infinity war we get
thanos talking about how he predicted
that titan was doomed that he was sure a
similar fate was going to happen to
other planets including earth and that
he needs to snap away half the
population but we never get why he has
these predictions only that he's the
only one who's smart enough to see the
inevitable given what we knew about him
at the time he just seemed to be a
committed malthusian zealot concerned
about resource management but now with
eternals i think we have another
explanation thanos actually did know all
of this stuff because he himself was a
malfunctioning eternal during the
credits for eternals we're introduced to
well first we're introduced to probably
the worst cgi in a marvel movie ever pip
the troll
was it just me or did the dialogue just
not match up with this guy's lips at all
the cgi effects here were like i was
watching the star wars special edition
anyway pip's the hype man for a
character named arrows also known by the
nickname star fox you're a barrel roll
yeah that joke's not gonna get old and
we're told that just like in the comics
eros is also an eternal who is also
thanos's brother which seems to suggest
that thanos himself was an eternal okay
so let's talk about thanos and eros for
a minute here in the comics they didn't
originally have anything to do with
eternals or celestials but then a retcon
came along which did make them part of
the eternals in fact that was part of
the explanation for why thanos was the
mad titan he was psychologically
traumatized from being bullied as a kid
because even though he himself was an
eternal he'd been born with a recessive
gene that made him look more like one of
the deviants i.e that's why he's huge
purple and you know the whole washboard
chin whereas eros was not only
traditionally attractive he has no joke
the power to make you sexually attracted
to him a villain for the metoo era if
i've ever seen one in short we have the
movie outright naming thanos as the sole
reason the emergence was delayed thereby
saving earth for five extra years we
have comic evidence showing thanos was
an eternal as well as an end credit
scene that suggests the exact same thing
so the pieces are lined up to prove that
thanos knew what he was doing all along
why then was he going around talking
about limited resources rather than hey
i'm doing this because you're all gonna
die when the space egg hatches well i
propose to you that he knew but also
kinda didn't know in eternals we learned
that angelina jolie's character thena
came down with an eternal specific
mental illness called madwiry this
caused her to have apocalyptic visions
and lash out at her teammates midway
through the movie it's revealed that
these moments of madness are actually
glitches in her programming when she
gets to see glimpses of the team's
previous planetary destructions what if
this or something like it is what
happened to thanos think about it if he
and eros are also eternals it stands to
reason that he could have had a similar
breakdown or had similar visions
revealing the truth about what's really
gonna happen when the world's population
reaches the dunmark but maybe not a
complete or coherent vision so his
interpretation of what he saw and felt
became militant population balance
instead of hey guys what if we're
actually a growth machine that feeds a
giant star child living inside the
planet why else would mad wiry be a plot
point in an already overstuffed movie
like eternals so that's a theory looking
backwards thanos was right yet again but
for good measure i wanted to include a
short theory looking forwards as well
when confronted about the nature of life
and death in the universe by cersei you
know real casual conversation there are
shem talks in pretty stark terms about
how if the celestials don't keep on
cultivating the cosmos everything will
fall to darkness now in the comics the
actual how and why of the celestials
changes all the time but a consistent
thing is that they're old as heck
representing the emergence of the first
light energy in the universe therefore
they are enemies of emptiness and
darkness on the cosmic scale and in the
marvel comics universe cosmic darkness
isn't just a what it's a who you see
this guy his name is null and i'm
thinking eternals just set him up as one
of the mcu's next big cosmic bad guys in
the comics null is supposedly the
embodiment of darkness a creature of
pure absolute evil and destruction who
seeks only to destroy all light life in
existence that makes the celestials his
ultimate enemies and he's been trying to
kill him off ever since they first
appeared the big floating head nowhere
from the guardians movies like i
mentioned earlier that used to be a
celestial and null was the one who did
the chopping using his weapon all black
the necro sword a sword that would later
fall into the hands of a character named
gore the god butcher a character that
wouldn't know it is about to be played
by christian bale in the upcoming thor
movie love and thunder now this weapon
in particular is interesting because
it's so much more than a sword it's
actually established to be a living
parasitic organism that's existed for
billions of years in fact in the comics
lore it's the first and most powerful
symbiote ever made with all black by
aside null assembles his first true army
the symbiote race huh that reminds me
who just got zapped into the mcu during
a post-credits scene oh yeah venom and
eddie at the end of venom two what
coincidental timing and this isn't just
me pulling out some loose threads either
in the end credit scene with dane
whitman we see him reach for a sword and
the glassy black polish on the blade
starts to shimmer and jump towards his
fingertips in a way that is not too
dissimilar from the way symbiotes react
in the venom movies now let me make this
clear i'm not saying that that sword is
all black it's more likely to be the
ebony blade sword that's actually hinted
at earlier in the movie when then is
practicing her swordsmanship but even
still all of it from the mention of
cosmic darkness to the sudden appearance
of symbiotes to a living blade heck even
the ebony blade itself is also traceable
to null's war against the celestials all
of it seems to pave the way for no
because here's what i think is the most
interesting takeaway of all this i don't
think we saw the good guys win in
eternals cersei herself questions
whether stopping the emergence was the
right move and honestly i don't think it
was regardless of the value of humanity
which honestly the movie itself is kind
of split on the actions of the eternals
in this movie were short-sighted saving
one planet at the expense of billions
that coupled with our heroes quest to
let the other eternals know the truth
about their existence sets in motion a
series of dominoes that definitely looks
like it's gonna wind up killing off a
bunch of celestials opening the door to
an era of darkness an era of no but hey
let's be honest with ourselves we all
know the marvel movie that we're all
really excited about is spider-man no
way home even as i write this it's
trending on twitter with like a hundred
thousand tweets that a new spider-man
poster just dropped with da da green
goblin from sam raimi's spider-man well
you guys can catch up on that first
appearance of that iconic villain
literally nowhere here in the u.s you
actually have to pay full price to rent
it or buy it wherever you're gonna try
to stream it but it is available to
stream over in netflix germany which you
can access thanks to our sponsor for
today's episode nordvpn did you know
that there are global databases that
tell you where in the world movies are
available to stream on netflix with
websites like that plus nord you
actually have unstoppable watching power
as disney puts more and more of its
movies behind disney plus it's getting
harder and harder to find their stuff
streaming on surfaces that you might
already own but i can tell you thanks to
sites like these movies like iron man
are still available to stream in only
two countries germany and spain but with
nordvpn two countries one country
doesn't matter that content is still
only two clicks away with nord you can
open up an entire world of content
that's otherwise inaccessible to you at
your specific location with over 5400
servers across 59 countries you can
essentially unlock a never-ending
streaming library nord is the trusted
online security solution used by over
hundreds of thousands of internet users
worldwide myself included with nordvpn
your info stays safe behind a wall of
next generation encryption it masks your
ip so you can keep your browsing to
yourself so absolutely nobody will be
able to see all the dumb things that
you're googling from day to day not even
nord with their strict no logs policy
they don't track collect or share your
private data your business remains your
business and as a sponsor for today's
episode nord is offering you theorists a
huge discount on their two-year plan
plus an additional one month for free
and they've made it incredibly easy to
sign up literally all you have to do is
head over to nordvpn.com
film theory or even better just click
the link in the top line of the
description take advantage of nord's
worldwide servers and ensure your
privacy online thanks again to nordvpn
for sponsoring today's episode and as
always thanks for watching